welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for obi-wan kenobi or should i
say
because duel of the fates is back in our
ears and all of the ghosts of obi-wan's
past are back to haunt him as he strives
to protect a young luke skywalker ahead
of his rematch with darth vader i loved
this trailer and i'm gonna break it down
frame by frame because it is filled with
awesome star wars easter eggs it just
includes subtle details that you just
might have overlooked so let's go
[Music]
the fight is done
we lost
the trailer opens with and it gets
skywalker's favorite stuff sand it
coarsely and roughly and irritatingly
gets everywhere under the twin sons of
tatooine in the music there's this
magical little riff
the great john williams is returning to
the music for this series and this riff
is played on a celeste which john
williams loves to muse like in his harry
potter theme
[Music]
or if you remember the opening shot of
the last jedi teaser there's a little
riff there
[Music]
actually the music in the first section
of this trailer is john williams theme
from revenge of the sith called the
battle of the heroes
[Music]
just showing how after all these years
obi-wan is still haunted by the memory
of his friend's betrayal and what he had
to do to him obi-wan writes an eop a
tattooing animal first scene in phantom
menace
[Music]
but also the steed obi-wan was last seen
writing when he left baby luke with
anakin's stepbrother owen lars and his
wife beru in the final scene of revenge
of the sith this series will take place
10 years later in the year 9 bby that's
9 years before the events of a new hope
this is the middle period when obi-wan
an exile under the alias of ben kenobi
keeps a watchful eye over young luke
skywalker keeping him hidden from the
empire as a farm boy living with his
uncle owen and his aunt peru now various
other star wars titles over the years
have touched on obi-wan's time during
this period saving young luke's life at
various points as owen would warn him to
stay away and then actually at one point
saving owen from black kirstentin that
wookie who just showed up in boba bed
giving bk that scar that we saw in his
head and then at another point later
than the show when lucas 12 he saved him
from a crate dragon actually see obi-wan
walking into town and slicing off a
piece of meat this actually might be a
slab of crate dragon meat from one that
he had butchered obi-wan laments the
fight is done
we lost
yeah you'll notice his voice sounds a
bit echoey here as if he might be
speaking these words while in a
meditative state communicating perhaps
with yoda or maybe with the force ghost
of qui-gon jinn since in revenge of the
sith yoda told obi-wan that he would
teach him how to reconnect with the
ghost of his old master an old friend
has learned the path to immortality
your old master
qui-gon how to commune with him
i will teach you
so let us all pray liam neeson returns
to the series to impart this very
particular set of skills moving on
[Music]
stay hidden
so obi-wan watches over the lars
homestead looking just as it did in a
new hope with owen and brew even wearing
pretty much the same outfits that they
wore in that first film actually this is
dark but they are standing in the same
exact spot where luke will later find
their corpses burnt when the
stormtroopers torched the home meanwhile
10 year old luke plays as a pilot it
looks like he's actually wearing pod
racing goggles and the way he pant mimes
operating the controls and leans just
looks so much like young anakin piloting
during that pod race and right as
obi-wan pushes in on luke the moment he
zooms in on him john williams battle of
the heroes theme transitions so smoothly
into the classic force theme
[Music]
stay hidden
let's move on
the key
to hunting jedi
baby what a needle drop john williams
doula the fates is of course best known
from phantom menace
[Music]
but the music was always bigger than
just darth maul's theme because it's
really come back throughout star wars
titles for the lyrics of the song john
williams translated an old welsh poem
called battle of the trees into the
sanskrit language he wanted to frame
this duel as a kind of pagan religious
ceremony almost like the spirits of both
sides of this conflict the jedi and the
sith shrieking like a greek chorus
egging on their mortal champions and
that same kind of battle is still being
waged now as obi-wan faces darth vader
once more as he faces the inquisitors
and maybe also faces a rematch with maul
because this is set one year after the
events of soloist star wars story which
established maul as the powerful head of
the crimson dawn crime organization now
in star wars rebels which is several
years after this maul will eventually
track down obi-wan to tatooine but this
is something he would not yet know at
this point of this show so that rematch
would not go down on tatooine but we do
see obi-wan go off-world in this trailer
either way maul could simply cameo in
some other scene that would set him upon
his revenge quest in rebels at least
give sam whitworth one more chance to
reprise this
then an inquisitor shuttle speeds across
this ocean planet towards his fortress
this is the ocean moon of ner and this
is the fortress inquisitorius so let's
talk about the inquisitors originally
the jedi hunters from the 1987
role-playing game inquisitors were
introduced in rebels explored further in
the 2015 darth vader comics and in the
jedi fallen order game they are a squad
of four sensitive beings trained by
darth vader to hunt down jedi survivors
of order 66. they're led by the grand
inquisitor voiced in rebels by jason
isaacs and played here by rupert friend
turned rupert beau in season one he
lures kanan jairus and ezra bridger to a
trap using the mummified remains of the
jedi master luminara unduly the grand
inquisitor dies at the end of that
season there are some things far more
frightening than death
[Music]
but he was later revealed to be one of
those jedi guards in clone wars who
helped arrest ahsoka tano when she was
falsely accused of bombing the jedi
temple and then later he helped arrest
the true culprit berisofi but from that
experience he learned the flaws in the
jedi orthodoxy and that's what opened
him up to be corrupted by palpatine and
it was suggested palpatine did that to
help expedite the fall of the jedi
temple now the fortress inquisitorius is
a secret location after the inquisitors
were forced to relocate from coruscant
so that now they're really off the books
the moon of ner is actually very close
to mustafar where vader's castle now
stands their shuttles which we've seen
in concept art have a two-pronged tip
that matches the two-prong tower of
vader's castle of course we visit this
underwater fortress in the game fall in
order and that game reveals the
backstory of the inquisitor named the
second sister trilla suduri former
padawan to sir ajunda the second sister
goes on to fight calcus and in defeat
nearly forgives her former master but is
executed by darth vader other
inquisitors include the fifth brother
and the seventh sister from season two
of rebels who tried to kill kanan jarrus
and ezra bridger and an arc that also
introduces the eighth brother an
inquisitor who'd been trying to track
down maul all three of these inquisitors
end up killed there was also the sixth
brother who had tried to kill ahsoka
tano but ahsoka defeated him taking his
blades kyber crystals and purifying them
white which is why in rebels and
mandalorian season 2 ahsoka has those
twin white lightsabers now if you look
closely on the fortress landing pad that
looks like a lamina class shuttle there
that's the same kind of ship vader and
other imperial vips used for
transportation so vader may be present
here checking in on to the next patience
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail so the grand inquisitor
faces down what looks like a cantina
barkeep on tatooine his armor looks as
it doesn't rebels though here it has a
badge that he did not have before maybe
he's a special designation he gets from
the emperor that he loses after his
failures on this series now later in the
trailer the inquisitor riva a major
character who we're gonna be following
on the show played by moses ingram stops
a runner dead in his tracks in the same
cantina and in this shot you can see
riva in the background on the right and
then on the left the inquisitor with a
wide head piece this is actually the
fifth brother from rebels now in live
action played by sung kang aka han from
the fast and the furious films now
sometimes i have to analyze this footage
while i am out on the go and when i am
doing that the last thing i want to
worry about is my earbuds falling out
but i avoid that nightmare scenario with
raycon thanks to raycon for sponsoring
this episode raycon's got everyday
earbuds with optimized gel tips for the
perfect fit it makes them comfortable
and they do not budge here are said gel
tips you just figure out which one your
head hole needs and slip it right on
they're not going anywhere
i can play with my dog all day long and
the earbuds never pop out
because if they do she'll eat them
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever they offer eight
hours of play time and a 32-hour battery
life that's long enough to listen to
like eight months of big question
podcasts and the recons are priced so
that you get quality audio at half the
price of other premium audio brands it's
no wonder why recon's everyday earbuds
have over 48 thousand five star reviews
so click the link in the description box
or go to buy raycon dot com slash new
rockstars to get 15 off your raycon
purchase and thanks again to raycon for
sponsoring this episode then we see a
skiff on tatooine transporting it looks
like workers including our man ben
kenobi just blending in i love how it
puffs out black smoke just making this
look like a really cheap polluting piece
of hardware meanwhile we hear the grand
inquisitor lecturing the key to hunting
jedi is patience they cannot help what
they are their compassion leaves a trail
now i know to a lot of you that sounded
like the voice of palpatine but
according to closed captioning on the
trailer it was actually the grand
inquisitor but it's a really interesting
perspective from a former jedi raised in
the jedi temple now patronizing the jedi
as a cult-like mental disorder george
lucas did originally conceive the empire
as space nazis and here the grand
inquisitor's assessment just evokes that
elitist mindset of the nazis and in this
way frames the inquisitors as a sort of
ss of the empire then inside the lower
sub-aquatic levels of the fortress
inquisitorius riva meets with the fifth
brother and another inquisitor with
these tendrils both have on their backs
the ringed double-bladed sabers carried
by all inquisitors which allowed them to
rotate the blades like a helicopter
rotor and you'll notice one of these
chairs has a tall two-pronged seat back
matching both their ships and vader's
castle so this may be vader's chair at
this table or the chair of the grand
inquisitor with a grand inquisitor
trying to embody vader's aesthetic then
on tatooine someone is suspended on
display perhaps the fugitive that riva
chases down looking like a message to
the locals not to harbor jedi but rather
than being hung from a noose i think
they'd be a bit dark for star wars i
wonder if this guy is actually being
force choked up over the ground and left
to suffocate among these bystanders is
joel edgerton returning as owen lars
sweating like a gumpton musta bar now it
seemed at first like these quitters
might be on tatooine looking for kenobi
himself but i don't know if they got
that close i don't know if obi-wan would
have been able to live for another nine
years after this rather i think there is
another force-sensitive fugitive who
fled the tatooine and just got too close
to obi-wan and this guy tragically
kenobi would not have been able to help
else risk his exposure and endanger luke
who is another force-sensitive kid the
inquisitors would probably target so
perhaps while chasing this random jedi
riva then senses another presence on
this planet that forces obi-wan to lead
her off world and try to throw her off
its tail moving on
the jedi code is like an itch
he cannot help it
where is he
okay here we see riva on the new planet
named daiyu described by the writer of
this series as a hong kong-like setting
with graffiti-ridden nightlife the neon
orabesh beside riva translates to er and
then to her left as she looks out
letter's spelling out milk kind of like
old man luke they love the lactate here
the inquisitor shuttle lands on tatooine
and then a shot of imperial officer
played by indira varma aka elaria sam
from game of thrones blaster drawn you
can tell by her badge red red red blue
she is the rank of captain in the
imperial navy then that female
inquisitor interrogates a lineup on the
daiu street you can see an orbesh sign
in the background translating to haas
market and as she walks right the last
suspect on the end is large fur covered
fella that we cut away from quickly a
wookie perhaps i mean it's just a
reminder that this is one year after
solo and chewbacca is at large as a
smuggler then we see this quick shot of
a new droid letters on his chest looking
like they translate to ned i'm wondering
if this could be camille nanjiani's
character which would keep with the
recent star wars tradition of comedians
voicing the droids phoebe waller bridge
matt barry richard iot alan tudyk then
the grand inquisitor fans his lightsaber
never breaking eye contact now this bald
dude does look a bit like the same head
shape as tamar morrison aka boba fett
aka every clone and clone trooper making
me wonder if this could be a runaway
clone trooper after order 66 being
interrogated and i only bring this up
because there is another shot in this
trailer showing the back side of some
really banged up looking stormtrooper
armor a little too scratched for
stormtrooper armor plus it looks like a
bit of blue plating there could this be
the clone trooper armor of rex could rex
be in the show i mean i know he wouldn't
die here because rex survives until
rebels i'm just saying this would be an
awesome opportunity to give tomorrow
some more screen time to make up for
those two episodes of the boba fett
series on to the next clip
[Music]
[Music]
okay here the fifth brother leads the
squad of stormtroopers on daiyu and yup
i translated all the orabesh on the far
right the last letters are e t maybe the
last letters of the word market and then
the blue sign at the top of frame i
think spells out the same thing as the
other blue sign in frame gungan snacks
and then on the right side we see some
pink letters with the green border also
the same word repeated with the orange
letters in the green border both
spelling out the word market and then on
the far right and orange once again milk
then we see a quick shot of two pods
blasting out into space these look a lot
like the pod used by yoda in revenge of
the sith to escape to dagobah this could
be the moment he and obi-wan separate to
their respective exiles which tells us
that we may see flashbacks to revenge of
the sith and flashbacks to the clone
wars era then we see a black's gloved
hand touching a symbol chalked on a wall
this is the sigil of the jedi order the
saber flanked by the wings this actually
may be riva finding a jedi hiding place
maybe the jedi have used these markings
to signal to each other and to keep the
hope alive then in an alley riva stares
down a gunslinger i'm thinking this is
obi-wan not wanting to out himself yet
by using his lightsaber instead opting
for the blaster so unsurprised i love
how the backlighting casts a long shadow
in front of a riva which gives her just
as fearsome edge but also suggests that
her opponent will have the light in his
eyes for this duel then we see a quick
rooftop shootout that looks like obi-wan
engaging with some blasters coming from
multiple different directions i do like
the detail of the laundry being hung up
to dry now they said they based daiyu on
hong kong and fun fact at mission
possible 3 j.j abrams actually had to
digitally remove shots of hanging
laundry in shanghai because local film
distributors didn't want shanghai to
look poor but in space hong kong deborah
chao leaves the laundry in then an
overhead shot shows a vent releasing
these green birds i'm not really sure
but the best known green bird in star
wars is mori the female convoy who
befriended ahsoka tano with a spiritual
connection to the daughter the mystical
deity of mortis now we did see mori
appear briefly in the mandalorian on the
planet corvus but until now i don't
think we've seen a whole flock of these
still i would love for ahsokatano to
cameo in the series since presumably
obi-wan will have to leave some
babysitter looking after luke when he
leaves tatooine and it would give a bit
more context to ahsoka and luke's
moments in the book of boba fett then
again rosario dawson would be having to
play an ahsoka 20 years younger than
when we've seen her before i don't know
how that would work so on to the last
clip
[Music]
okay after a close-up of obi-wan we get
the series title which if you look
closely snuck in the shape of obi-wan's
lightsaber on that eye then we hear the
iconic breathing of darth vader and we
know hayden christensen is coming back
in the series to have an epic rematch
with obi-wan kenobi it's super exciting
especially because if you listen closely
they use a specific music sting
this is john williams anakin's dark
deeds track from revenge of the sith
right after anakin slaughtered the
separatist leaders on mustafar and
bitterly stared into the lava and the
flames a tear rolling down his cheek
and i love that they remind us of this
moment because for me whenever i rewatch
revenge of the sith this right here was
hayden christensen's darkest performance
just simply his silent glower his inner
torment there is a reason hayden was
brought back for the series because
think about it if they just wanted vader
they could have brought back the team
they used for rogue one james earl jones
doing the voice a couple stuntmen doing
the performance but no they needed
hayden christensen because it's not just
darth vader with the mask that we're
returning to it is the grief-stricken
rage-filled human underneath that mask
so this john williams light motif is a
promise that we will see this face again
whether it's invader's breathing
apparatus or a close-up under the mask
the scarred face or maybe a different
form all together projected in astral
form obi-wan will have to look into
these eyes once more and lastly you
gotta love that blue lightsaber cutting
in to form the disney plus logo just
between this and the moon night leap in
the moon night trailer this is
essentially the house of mouse's new
tinkerbell swoosh over the castle and
i'm digging it now be sure to check in
monday here at new rockstars for wookie
leaks it's our weekly star wars reaction
q a at this point we are going full
county
also check out our great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching and oh i forgot to
say hello there so um goodbye there
[Music]
you